oh boy so many questions
so I can't really tell you who's gonna
ask this question but I'm sure the
question is going to be asked what the
heck is in your hair and why the are you
wearing so much makeup oh well so and so
that's a great question and let me
answer it for you I just got done
shooting an amazing new music video it's
gonna be out Monday so be sure to look
for it Monday morning is spoof of The
Ting Tings it's not money look for it in
your subscription box
it's about YouTube haters and while I
was filming this video I actually got
attacked Twitter questions I love you
princess Beth wants to know my favorite
vegetable is and I'm gonna answer that
question
carrots xx 5 m 8x excellence and ly I'm
down on the station with the other
youtubers I wasn't it I died so I guess
that's why I'm not anymore
I'm excited for this video response
question because I've been meaning to
answer her questions for a while okay
Kelly what's your question
hey IJ I want to know would you ever be
a panda bear it was actually yeah I
would and I'm putting a little bit I
can't just just - salt in ketchup I'd
also like to know what's your favorite
foreign country
my favorite foreign country I don't know
I've actually never really left the
United States I went to Mexico once what
Canada once that's it I'd also like to
know what would your reaction be if you
saw Ashton could spit when he asked you
out on a date and that's funny that you
actually asked me a question about
Ashton Kutcher because some of you guys
may have seen the video that I did
actually get to meet him but sorry Kelly
you didn't ask me on a date because I'm
pretty sure that his wife would not
approve
I dunno whatever treatise thanks for
watching this episode of ask IJ I'll see
you guys next time as always don't
forget to leave your comments add video
responses be sure you rate this little
video 5 stars cuz you know what it
deserves it my mom and rate of 5 stars
so why won't you